die zuschauer was denken sie wenn sie
diese menschen hier sehen das sind
taliban in afghanistan
diejenigen die terror verbreiten die
tagtäglich für ihr schreckliches regime
kämpfen angeblich im namen gottes würden
sie sich für einige tage in die hände
dieser menschen begeben
unser kollege paul ronzheimer der hat
genau das gemacht er war bei den taliban
mittendrin um ihn um der welt zu
berichten von diesem drama das sich da
aktuell in afghanistan abspielt nämlich
dem gnadenlosen vorrücken der taliban
stadt für stadt provinz für provinz
dieses video zeigt noch einmal wie
brutal die taliban dabei vorgehen
sie sehen hier afghanische spezialkräfte
die männer die haben sich eigentlich
ergeben
sie sehen es hoffentlich auch gleich die
erste kam er kurz auf die karte weil das
ist genau die geschichte dieses landes
aktuell die taliban rücken vorrücken vor
die dunkelrote flecken das sind schon
wieder von den taliban zurückgeholte
gebiete und mittendrin euro dieses video
das sollte ich ihnen hier gerade zeigen
die taliban die afghanischen
spitzenplätze sehen sich hier die
ergeben sich mit handy hören schüsse die
taliban rufen kommt raus und dann
eröffnen sie obwohl sich die afghanen
spezialkräfte bereits gegeben haben
das feuer auf die wehrlosen menschen
schlachten sie ab 22 menschen wurden
getötet
der us-sender cnn hat heute die
authenzität dieses videos bestätigt ja
und das ist ein drama bei dem die welt
hinschauen muss über das die welt
berichten muss über das bild sich
entschieden hat intensiv zu berichten
mit paul ronzheimer der sich auf den weg
gemacht hat mitten in das taliban gebiet
und der diese geschichte mitgebracht hat
sie wollen wieder an die macht sie
wollen ihre scharia verankern halt vor
menschenleben machen sie dabei nicht
jeder der sich ihnen in den weg stellt
wird ausgelöscht haben die offizielle
genehmigung bekommen taliban seite dass
wir in die region reisen dürfen aber so
richtig wissen wir natürlich nicht was
uns da erwartet
vor allem seit dem truppenabzug der us
amerikaner und der nato erobern die
extremistischen taliban immer mehr
gebiete in afghanistan
ihr nächstes großes ziel die hauptstadt
kabul
wie ist eure situation die taliban sind
überall in afghanistan haben viele
provinzen erobert man glaubt ihr ist das
ganze land unter kontrolle der taliban
doch kabul wir werden das nicht so
schnell tun
wir bewegen uns wirklich sehr langsam
voran damit wir unseren fortschritt
nicht schaden die großen städte die
gerade wieder aufgebaut wurden sind im
moment so wunderschön und genau dafür
bewegen wir uns zu langsam und
vorsichtig wir wollen unsere städte und
die infrastruktur nicht zerstören und
vor allem keine leute gefährden
[Musik]
wir sind in der provinz wardak und
hinter mir sind viele taliban-kämpfer
sehr günstigen linien gegeben hin zu
filmen und zu zeigen wie sie diesen ort
eingenommen haben und so wie hier auf
diesen straßen sieht das gibt immer mehr
regionen afghanistans aus den die
taliban haben die macht übernommen
wir sehen hier viele kämpfer viele
taliban krieger zivilisten auf der
straße haben wir dagegen kaum
der abzug der bundeswehr vor knapp zwei
wochen eine entscheidung die vor allem
die taliban freund
[Musik]
wir sind froh dass sie unser land
verlassen haben jeder von uns ist froh
dass sie es ohne widerstand getan haben
aber sollten sie widerstand leisten dann
sind wir bereits sie gewaltsam aus dem
land zu vertreiben
das große ziel der extremisten in
afghanistan von 1996 als die taliban
nach jahren des bürgerkriegs die macht
übernahmen und das land zu einem
gottesstaat machten was wäre eure
nachricht an die westliche welt würde
afghanistan unter der kontrolle der
taliban aussehen der grund warum wir
kämpfen ist die scharia und ein
islamisches system aber wir wollen auch
ein gutes verhältnis zu allen anderen
diplomatischen ländern wir werden aber
keinem land erlauben sich in afghanistan
einzumischen
wir werden keinen ärger macht von
unserem land gibt für andere länder
keine gefahr aus wir werden versuchen
eine gute beziehung herzustellen
eine gute beziehung zum westen ein ding
der unmöglichkeit zu groß das leid das
die taliban verursacht haben und weiter
verursachen wenn sie nicht aufgehalten
werden
eines ist sicher von alleine werden
diese extremisten nicht stoppen
[Musik]
unfassbare einblicke die uns frau damit
bringt aus afghanistan wo er welt
exklusiv berichtet bei den taliban ist
mir liefen gerade wirklich ein kalter
schauer über den rücken und wir schalten
jetzt zu paul ronzheimer nach
afghanistan wo er für uns berichtet paul
wo seid ihr jetzt und wie war das bei
den taliban kämpfern bekommt man da
bevor man da in dieses gebiet reingeht
irgendeiner art der sicherheitsgarantie
wir sind jetzt wieder in kabul wir waren
gestern den ganzen tag mit den taliban
kämpfern unterwegs sind dann aus
sicherheitsgründen auch nicht über nacht
geblieben was die genehmigungen angeht
muss man sagen dass wir wochenlang mit
den taliban kämpfern den verhandlungen
standen am ende hat ein sogenanntes
militär komitee das dann halboffiziell
abgezeichnet dass ging über lokale
kontakte hier in afghanistan
was eine garantie der sicherheit angeht
da muss man sagen das weiß man natürlich
nicht ganz genau wir haben uns so weit
abgesichert wie man konnte aber was dann
vor ort passiert wie auch lokale kräfte
dann reagieren das ist immer unsicher
aber ich muss sagen für den konkreten
fall jetzt in wardak wo wir waren da
haben sich die taliban an genau das
gehalten was sie uns vorher versprochen
hatten
sie sehen ich also zurück in kabul nach
diesem ausflug in die taliban regionen
jetzt wissen wir die taliban rücken vor
provinz für provinz stadt für stadt wie
lange wird das dauern bis die auch an
der hauptstadt klopfen an kabul
die situation hier in afghanistan hat
sich weiter verschärft muss man sagen
die taliban rücken weiter vor und wenn
man mit hier regierungsvertretern in
kabul spricht dann bekommt man das
gefühl dass sie eigentlich keine antwort
haben auf dieses vordringen der taliban
und wenn man sie dann fragt ja was
machen sie denn wenn sich hier auch nach
kabul kommen dann heißt es immer wieder
ja wir hoffen auf eine
verhandlungslösung wir hoffen darauf
dass die taliban nicht so radikal sind
am ende wie in den 90ern aber ich habe
mit mehreren kämpfern in diesem gebiet
darüber gesprochen und die haben uns
gesagt nein wir wollen alles genauso wie
1996 als wir nach kabul ein vielen wir
wollen dass das scharia gesetz wir
wollen die hinrichtungen steinigung all
das was aus unserer sicht ist so grausam
macht und natürlich auch aus der sicht
so viele frauen so vieler anderer
menschen die hier im regierungsgebäude
in afghanistan geben halt vielleicht ist
es eine etwas naive frage angesichts
dieser langen kriegsgeschichte des
landes aber kann es irgendwie frieden
geben wie weit soll das gehen
eine chance für frieden sehe ich
momentan nicht denn die taliban wollen
das ganze land das erklären sie immer
wieder die vermeintlichen
verhandlungslösungen was man damit den
friedensverhandlungen versucht hat und
den usa die sind kolossal gescheitert
denn da haben die taliban angekündigt
dass sie bereit sind dafür dass sie
bereit sind für verhandlungen aber hier
sozusagen auf dem boden hier in
afghanistan sieht man dass sie immer
weiter vorrücken dass sie immer weiter
vor marschieren und es droht ein langer
langer krieg
paul ronzheimer für diese ja unfassbar
bilder die du mitgebracht hast aus dem
taliban gebiet für deine worte aus kabel
bei uns im studio bild chef julian
reichelt du warst selbst oft dort wo
paul gerade ist in kabul im land
unterwegs erst mal ganz emotional was
empfindest du wenn wir auf diese karten
schauen
die zeigen wie die taliban im grunde
stunde für stunde tag für tag vorrücken
wenn wir diese drastischen bilder aus
dem land sehen wenn wir wissen das sind
alles gebiete in denen wird niemand mehr
in die schule gehen da werden keine
frauen auf die straße gehen da herrscht
ein terrorregime
ich empfinde das was vermutlich alle
reporter empfinden die afghanistan über
jahre und jahre gekapert hatten haben
nämlich dass nichts von dem was uns
unsere westlichen regierung unsere
politik erzählt haben über den
fortschritt den ist in afghanistan gehen
würde das nichts von dem je gestimmt hat
das war das muss man sagen den menschen
die afghanistan über jahre gecovert
haben so wie ich aber da geht es nicht
um mich da geht's um viele viele andere
mutige journalisten immer bewusst dass
die afghanen die wir dort vor ort
getroffen haben immer gesagt haben weil
der oft zitierte fast schon phrasen auf
der legendäre satz der taliban ihr habt
die uhr
wir haben die zeit das war das was man
immer gehört hat die taliban haben immer
gewusst dass der westen ist in
afghanistan nicht aushalten würde
alexander der große hat sich ausgehalten
die russen haben es da nicht ausgehalten
die amerikaner haben es mit ihrer
unterstützung für die modelle die nicht
ausgehalten sie wussten immer wir würden
eines tages gehen und sie haben
eigentlich immer geschaut
das sind aber schöne gepanzerte
fahrzeuge oder das sind aber schöne
gewähre die wird der westen vermutlich
da lassen und man muss sagen die taliban
haben mit allem recht gehabt wenn man
sich die bewaffnung auf den
beeindruckenden bildern die paul uns mit
seinem großartigen fotografen einmal
windharfe mitgebracht hat man sieht
neues bewaffnung neueste amerikanische
gewehre zielfernrohre alles an
hochmoderner militär technologie die man
sich nur wünschen kann
als durchschnittlicher islamist man muss
leider sagen nach 20 jahren überlassen
wir ein land das sich im kern nicht
verändert hat das einzige was sich
verändert hat ist die von deutschland
amerikanischen steuerzahlern finanzierte
bewaffnung der schlimmsten islam
auf der welt wir haben da ein
20-jähriges aufbauprogramm für das
nächste taliban-regime gestartet die
sind top motiviert wie man sieht die
sind jetzt bestens bewaffnet bestens
ausgestattet sie haben sogar relativ
massive unterstützung in der bevölkerung
weil westliches militär dort auch immer
alles andere war als beliebt immer als
in wasser wahrgenommen wurde
man kann fast sagen da die taliban er in
anderen zeiträumen denken als hier das
den eigentlich gar nichts besseres hätte
passieren können als diese 20-jährige
zeit des westlichen militärs dort und
all den schönen gewähren all der
munition und aldingen gepanzerten
fahrzeugen die sie dort jetzt von uns
übernommen haben mit schönen grüßen
unter anderem vom deutschen steuerzahler
und das hat ja auch jetzt konsequenzen
für uns 3500 agora die bundesregierung
gesagt sollen kommen finnland hat gesagt
wir setzen die abschiebungen aus was
wird das jetzt alles hier auch auslösen
sollen auch hier jetzt die abstimmungen
ausgesetzt werden was wird das was wir
da auf uns zu also vielleicht einfach
mal ein ganz klarer und einfacher punkt
für unsere zuschauer warum ist das
wichtig was gerade in afghanistan
passiert ganz einfach weil die
amerikaner mit dem ozean dazwischen
davon erstmal nicht betroffen sind was
dort passieren es kann sein dass sie
eines tages wieder durch terror
betroffen sind sowie anleihen eleven vor
genau 20 jahren
aber erstmal von den direkten
auswirkungen wären sie vermutlich nicht
betroffen sein
aber wir denn das was dort gerade
passiert wird natürlich ein
flüchtlingsstrom richtung europa und da
es in deutschland immer das beliebteste
land auslösen ganz einfacher punkt wenn
der marktplatz in jeder beliebigen stadt
kundus wo die bundeswehr war geöffnet
hat bleiben die afghanen gerne in kunduz
weil sie einkaufen gehen können weil sie
sich sicher fühlen wenn zum beispiel die
bundeswehr daneben steht bei ihr leben
schritt für schritt besser wird wenn der
markt zu macht weil die taliban ihn
kontrollieren dann möchten die afghanen
nicht in kunduz bleiben sondern dann
sagen sie
sie nehmen lieber den weg nach zum
beispiel deutschland auf sich deswegen
relativ leicht entweder und das war
immer die bittere realität entweder wir
kommen nach afghanistan mit der
bundeswehr oder afghanistan kommt zu uns
das ist die wahl vor der widerstände das
ist die wahl die von der deutschen
politik dort einfach komplett ignoriert
worden ist abzug aus afghanistan heißt
nicht das ende
in afghanistan einsatzes sondern dem
beginn der nächsten flüchtlingswelle aus
afghanistan weil afghanistan unter den
taliban unerträglich werden wird
deswegen wäre es in unserem interesse
mit deutschen soldaten in afghanistan
wie es immer so schön heißt
fluchtursachen vor ort zu bekämpfen
das leben für afghanen in afghanistan
besser zu machen anstatt zu warten dass
sie ein neues leben in deutschland das
heißt auch deswegen ist paul im moment
darum ihn zu hause in münchen in
paderborn in eisenhüttenstadt zu sagen
das was da im fernen kabul im fernen
afghanistan im moment passiert das
könnte in kürze zu ihnen nach hause
kommen und wir erinnern uns einmal an
dieser stelle an ein zitat des
bundesinnenministers horst seehofer der
vor kurzem erst gesagt hat dass
abschiebung nach afghanistan
grundsätzlich möglich sind das hat er
uns nämlich bei bild gesagt mitte juni
also das ist gerade mal knapp monat alt
dieses zitat das könnte sich dramatisch
ändern jetzt wir haben gesehen wie das
da in den gebieten zu gehen wo die
taliban zunehmend ihr terrorregime
wieder errichten in weiten teilen des
landes das heißt da kommen die leute her
aus afghanistan die vor den taliban
wegrennen möglicherweise wahrscheinlich
zu uns und die werden wir dann auch
nicht mehr so leicht zurückstecken
können also das ist vielleicht ein ganz
zentraler punkt wenn die bundesregierung
davon redet dass sie abschied gibt's
noch lange nicht ab ja darüber ist in
den letzten jahren immer nur geredet
worden
tatsächliche policies dazu gibt es nicht
die frage ist dann ja auch mal ein wenig
ab habe ich dann irgendwann noch mal
daran können wir ganz kurz auch drauf
gucken julian weil du sagst die policy
ist zwar abschieben aber deswegen wird
es noch lange nicht gemacht zeigt mal
kurz die zahlen in den vergangenen
jahren die abschiebe zahlen die sind
jahr für jahr immer wieder
zurückgegangen und sind im chor o na ja
0 quasi gewesen also 98 abschiebung 20
21 bisher im vorjahr im corona jahr 2020
137 also das ist auch eine garagenwand
waren sie natürlich relativ niedriger er
muss man sagen da ging es meistens nur
um kriminelle um schwere straftäter und
nicht um die frage wollen wir eigentlich
grundsätzlich und das ist die frage der
sich die bundesregierung die letzten
fünf jahren nicht gestellt hat was ist
eigentlich unsere policy wollen wir als
deutschland das afghanen bei uns schutz
suchen oder wollen wir dass afghanen in
afghanistan so sicher und so gut wie
möglich leben
die frage ist bis heute nicht
beantwortet vor der frage druckt man
sich weg und da wo man sie beantworten
könnte nämlich durch den einsatz von
militär auch das etwas was deutschland
lernen muss langsamer einsatz von
militär heißt nicht grundsätzlich dass
man krieg führen will oder sich gegen
invasoren verteidigt sondern militär
setzt man einen zur durchsetzung
nationaler oder internationaler
interesse und natürlich ist es in
unserem interesse dass afghanistan
stabil ist wir tun jetzt aber gerade das
gegenteil wir d stabilisieren
afghanistan in einer unzumutbaren weise
und natürlich wird das
flüchtlingsbewegungen auslösen kleines
beispiel noch aus dem beitrag den paul
mudter für uns gestern geschickt haben
da haben sie einen taliban richter
getroffen der ihn noch mal erklärt wie
man in zukunft umgehen wird mit menschen
weil sie frauen sind oder mit menschen
weil sie homosexuell sind und der
richter hat paul ronzheimer dort
berichtet ist es ist so absurd das ist
fast komisch wäre wenn es nicht so
unfassbar traurig wäre in den
auswirkungen vor ort und das ist zum
beispiel für homosexuelle zwei arten der
todesstrafe gibt das steinigen und eine
mauer von mindestens aber ich habe
richtig im kopf drei meter höhe auf den
sitzen den delinquenten sprich
homosexuellen zu werfen und das sagt
einfach auch viel über afghanistan aus
so absurd das klingt ein land das so
wenig mauern und erbautes hat macht sich
dann ernsthaft gedanken darüber dass man
die wenigen mauern die in diesem land
erbaut worden sind dann am besten auf
homosexuelle wirft das ist an einer an
einer grauenvollen tödlichen
mörderischen skurrilität auch nicht mehr
zu bieten er überbieten und natürlich
werden menschen vor dieser mörderischen
skurril
die flucht ergreifen und natürlich ist
ihr sehnsucht deutschland
sie wollen diesen brutalen leben einfach
hingehen ich kann auch diesen beitritt
julian erwähnter es nur noch mal
empfehlen den finden sie natürlich auch
auf bild.de den bericht aus aus
afghanistan von unseren kollegen paul
ronzheimer mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bild schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren